字幕志愿者 杨栋梁
好,大家晚安
这个又到了我们的周三直播时间
周三直播时间
好,一开始欢迎各位加一下这4个QR Code
一开始还没到九点
先聊天一下
赵华最爱的大企奇
这不能念错
念错等下被投诉
美元指数快突破前高了
美元指数突破前高
这个要小心
这个钱流到美元
那就麻烦了
钱就回去了
好 那我们再来看
哎
我今天这边打错了哈
嗯
今天是抽LG
滑鼠
哦
今天不一样了哈
好了
9点了哦
哎
各位有听到声音吗
有听到声音哦
那9点了
我们要开始直播了
然后一开始呢
请各位加一下这4个QR Code
有粉丝团
LINE AT官方社团
跟Youtube
YouTube
粉丝团Lite 观众专业 YouTube
那粉丝团呢
我们会贴全镇主力进出的状况
对短线还有
波段呢都有帮助
因为我们会去观察一下
波段全镇主力在干嘛
那Lite 呢
最近比较少播啦
那官方社团有
有这个交易的知识也不错
YouTube上面有很多教学影片
好那今天呢
请各位呢在结束后呢
在我的频道留言
我们今天会抽这个
这个看起来非常时尚漂亮的LG滑鼠这个是正版的LG滑鼠还贴intel
不知道跟intel有什么关系
正版的LG滑鼠
这个是
这个LG正版
送给各位啦
这个是正品
为什么因为我的笔电
我又买一台笔电
买一台笔电呢
多一个滑鼠呢
这就来送给各位啦
那这滑鼠用起来还不错用
这个也蛮轻薄的
这个让你数钱数不完的滑鼠啦
数钱数不完的滑鼠
好
那我们今天这个欢迎加一下
加完之后呢再请各位加这个Telegram
Telegram有安卓版跟苹果版
在中文化系统再加入我的频道就可以使用啦
好
那直播注意事项
第一个请将YouTube滑指调到最高
第二个直播版全属理财宝跟讲师所有
请不要录制散播
第三个YouTube画质比FB好啊
可以转到YouTube观看
第四个直播提到的标的仅供教学研究
物作下单参考
更非投资建议
投资有很大的风险
没学过可不要下单啊
没学过可不要下单
投资有很大风险哦
像最近這個
我要去上一個節目
那節目的製作單位說
欸小哥你可不可以來講一下
講一下那個車店
車店族群
我說那車店族群今天可能會辛苦一點喔
為什麼
像今天有一檔股票呢
各位呢
今天有一檔股票我們來看一下喔
今天是禮拜三
禮拜三呢有兩檔股票呢都殺的有點慘啦
那一檔呢就是怎麼樣
就是杀骑马
这个美琪马
美琪马今天被杀了
变成杀骑马
为什么呢
各位呢我们从我们的筹码K线就看得懂
这个杀骑马
美琪马这档股票啊
美琪马这档股票
最近长期呈现主力卖超
但是突然又变买超
那这种突然又变买超呢
常常都是这个隔日冲造成的
突然又变买超是隔日冲造成的
隔天就容易殺一根黑K
最近很多股票都是這樣
例如說昨天的這個航空類股航空雙雄這個華航長長榮航昨天呢就大黑K
今天的這個殺琪瑪
殺美琪瑪另外呢
還殺一黨聚合
這都跟車店相關的
那我說當你們製作單位想做什麼主題的時候
那就常常這個主題代表怎麼樣
这主题代表这个散户太热了
所以呢每次看到那个讲的标题
我都很想跟他们讲
那我去这现场可以多讲一些他们的坏话吗
我不大想推荐股票
我特别喜欢在高档跟投资人讲
不要去追啊
你不要去追这档股票
像聚合不要去追
我们都还写在什么地方呢
我们还写在高档出货股里面
你不要追这档股票啦
你追这档股票很危险
很危险为什么
因为你会跟我对坐
因为我呢我会空一堆聚合
那为什么要空聚合呢
我们从筹码K线的主力买来超
就看得很清楚啦
他呢在高档是主力在出货的股票
这种股票很多老师在推哦
很多老师在推聚合哦
但是你会看筹码K线的话
你也知道
你也知道怎么样
你也知道这个在主力出货的嘛
那主力出货呢
这谁在买的啊
各位看一下
呃 散户在买
散户在买就是有问题嘛
就是有问题
散户在买就是有问题
那为什么散户会买呢
散户会买就是因为怎么样
他被一些老师鼓吹啊
或者是被社团的这个鼓吹啊
像这个
最近又有诈骗在联络我
他跟我讲说
他有个方案要我汇2000块
汇2000块都要户头
我就跟他讲说你这样子
你这样子欺骗人家都怕下地狱
你这个都是用名牌来骗人
但是呢我们都不是用名牌来跟各位讲
我们都是教各位怎么样
我们都教各位怎么样分辨
这个股票的筹码
当你会看股票的筹码的时候
你就不会像聚合这样
各位看今天聚合
散户又去追高啦
散户这两天聚合都去追高那中股票就是烂这个筹码就是烂那筹码就是爛呢他在这边证印之后呢很容易怎么样很容易后面会下来
震荡完很容易后面下来
所以这个呢你就要小心一点啦
中股票不要去追啦
好
今天呢会讲的就
我们今天讲的就会比较
多这个方面的东西啦
就教各位看筹码
好
那我们今天会用到理财宝软体
然后下载理财宝软体
立即下载
然后下一步下一步点选我同意
我们这个学员有说
他看到了这个我赚了涨停后
看到高档出货股快跑
恭喜你
我们高档出货股
写的正式时候
告诉你说
这聚合呢
他是一个高档出货股股票
非常的明显
因为我们有三大指标来
怎么样
有三大指标来验证
验证他是一个高档出货股
我待会就会交给各位啦
好
你下一步下一步我同意哦
然后你可以可以用
这个FB的账号
也可以用email就可以了啊
好那各位呢看一下
这个我的歌友筹币报
有19集
各位可以慢慢看啊
里面有教很多科
比较基本的股票的知识啊
其实你看完这19集之后
你的程度一定超过PR值90
PR值90
为什么
因为这方间
方间这个做股票的技术
普遍来讲还是非常的差
非常差
有怎么看得出来呢
例如说最近
最近你假如去看一些
这个选股比赛里面发现
这个礼拜
大家选来选去
继续都是负的
但是这礼拜呢
虽然我们多单还是一样会赔钱
但是我們的一些空方策略
這禮拜不是這禮拜
是這個月大獲全勝
這個月呢我的一些短空的方面
短空的技巧
我們在放空實戰班呢
有教各位怎麼做短空
這個月呢你做短空
每天做每天賺
因為這個月太好做了
隔天前一天只要是
我們講前一天只要是
這個漲停很多隔日從主力在賣的
隔天都是怎麼樣
隔天都是
开低走低
开高走低
反正后面都是走低
这个非常的好做
非常好做
你只要会研究筹码
你有上过
胖空实战课
你就知道
该怎么做
那这些交易呢会让你怎么样
会让你去补一下你空方的亏损
会让你补一下空方的
跟着
会让你弥补一下你的多方亏损
我做多有亏损
我今天会贴我的亏损对账单给各位看哦
这个我们往下看啊
好
我们先先来讲一下这个中奖名单
中奖名单
石先生
石头的石
那以前有梗叫
那个淑先生
请问你是哪个先生
淑先生
哪个淑
淑头的淑
淑头的石先生
好
十先生呢
今年六月开始接触股票
刚开始是看理财答案
就学习
特别喜欢小哥的
歌有筹必报
那这段期间重复看了三次
有PV马上加入
真的很喜欢小哥
对筹码精确的分享
叫全正慢压
哦那目前有上过小哥当冲课程
期货课程全正课程
让自己像海明班西周
像小哥一样散发自信
希望可以抽到软体序号
恭喜啦
哦
数头的数啊
好
来第二个呃林玉成
林玉成先生
很早以前就听过小哥的名号
但受到过往一堆古海民师的荼毒
哦
只学了又是一个新的老师而已
这个我跟其他老师有个很大的不一样就是
我们的学费
我们特别讲我们的学费是
一个月交易税的不到千分之一
就是我
在1000个学生来上课
收的学费
不够付交易税
我们是非常有经验
学费又是方间
你看得到大概是最便宜的学费
好好
这跟一般老师不一样好
近期无意中看了好几次
歌有仇闭爆还有直播
尝试订阅PP
反正不ok的话顶多浪费1000块而已
毕竟坑过一堆学费
对啊不ok1000块而已
就不准你就退订
不准就退订就好了
但发现小哥真的准度很高
真的要我们避掉很多陷阱
就是订阅超值
好好这恭喜你
你也得到了软体
序号好
呃接下来呢是辛慈非常感谢佛星的小哥6月中订PP7月份小哥提醒航运要小心结果航运呢7月份是大崩盘了
结果没有认真劝
听劝把航运出掉
因为执念太深而惨赔
那这执念呢是什么执念呢
很多都是基本面的执念
那种基本面执念很恐怖哦
很恐怖哦各位
不只航运类股
像最近呢有些股票也跌很惨
例如說像這個最近
例如說敦泰
敦泰你看這個之前到29%的時候
有的人就說敦泰300塊很合理啦
本益比那麼低
300塊很合理
各位你看這籌碼你就知道敦泰有問題啊
為什麼
哪有人在高檔是散戶在買的啦
高檔散戶在買就是
就是有
這很怪嗎
高檔散戶買
那誰誰在賣
主力在賣
高档主力在卖股票
那就是有鬼
本益比再跟各位讲一次
本益比是过去是OK
本益比是过去的获利来算的
不是未来的获利来算的
你要好的本益比来吧
群创过低了吧
原本三倍
现在是2.9倍
2.9倍
你要低 低還有更低
好不好 低還有更低
那一天呢
這個群創在這邊漲停
一堆投顧老師又說
群創太便宜
趕快買件群創友達
我一看就知道
明天群創友達空爆他
我空了我還用499去空
一次掛499商空
為什麼
因為那個籌碼一看
各位你看主力賣超嘛
主力賣超隔日沖大買
隔天就是空
隔天就是空啊
你看后面还不是跌下来
跌下来嘛
所以公告财报那都是过去的事情
股票是看未来
再讲一次喔
看的是未来
三倍本益比
不够低啦
你看现在2.9倍了
搞不好有一天你会看到两倍
看到两倍本益比
你也不能买
那你什么时候可以买呢
告诉各位什么时候可以买
当全创跌得很低的时候
你看到他賠錢賠錢再賠錢
賠錢賠錢再賠錢
你已經看不到本益比了看不到本益比你就每天看著你看這個EPSG每季都賠錢近四季都賠錢這時候準備要買了懂齁
這個本益比是這樣子看的
這種景氣循環股就是怎麼樣
你要等到他賠錢的時候
股價很低的時候
關鍵分點買主力買的時候
才能買
那些看基本面本益比的
都是
也不大好意思在直播讲什么
反正就是
就是比看筹码的来的弱一点点
来的弱一点点
好不好
我们看筹码的稍微微微强一点点
我们知道在什么时候该放空
什么时候该做多
你对股价是可以稍微预测的
好吧
微预测
你可以预测
像昨天就微预测
今天可能会杀起码
前天就
前天就为一测
昨天可能会摔飞机
你看这个这个timing都抓得非常的好
我们timing抓得很好的
这个你你你订阅就知道
对对对对
又按错了
好
这个timing抓得很好啦
所以这个各位
不要太迷信基本面
方前一堆人在跟你讲基本面
那基本面比不上一碗泡面
好不好 比不上一碗泡面
为什么 因为除非你看到的是未来的基本面
你假如看到是当天的基本
你假如看到是之前的基本面
那是没用的 好不好 没用
你看最近很多财报都怎么样
财报创新高的隔天跌停
营收创新高的隔天大跌
对不对 一堆啊 为什么 没用
为什么 因为是股票在高档
股票在高档
这个利多没有用
筹码就是烂
就是烂
好
这个啊
再看这个学院
现在批批每天晚上听两次
最近也多上小哥的课
希望8月开始可以跟随小哥跟
群主你的高手学长学姐们的脚步
重新开始获利
合大赔分手
小赚和大赚
做好朋友
好这个希望你这样
恭喜你
来来看周梓杰非常感谢小哥订阅小哥PPA5个月了让我学习很多筹码上的知识也让我荷包满满小哥在PP上的提点超级准的
例如长龙大路在跑
而最近的面板是空点
而不是追点
你看
我们讲得很清楚
面板
面板不是追好不好
不要去追面板
那个就是一日行情
一日行情你去追
真的会套在高点
好
信小哥得现金
信小哥得钞票
我们都这样讲
那你去信其他人得股票
你喜欢股票去信别人
你要多信
你可以信很多人
你都可以得到满手的股票
你就一直买股
你都也卖不掉
因为套老卖不掉
那信筹码真的可预言
非常感谢小哥的教学
恭喜
好来
Rebecca
今天中有时间同步看直播
赶快留言
每周一次抽时间看直播
直播有很多pegbook
从原本懵懵懂懂
跟着小哥订阅来到7个月的时间
以前做多还只会杂杂存股
那其实比起课堂群组里的学长
真是嫩逼到一个不行
我们这个群组大家都还蛮爱表的
每天听小哥的笔记本
隔天开启模拟交易
慢慢抓到一点心得
时常恐惧会吞没的理智
好了
再看底下
看到学长们
学长姐们的对象三次
满满的羡慕跟激励
希望自己可以赚得盆满钵满
带爸妈游山玩水
很好
感谢小哥丛满分析
谢小世界快乐天堂路
恭喜你
这个得到了序号
得到序号
好
来接着大
大企期得奖者
是
优利令
林先生
每天都期待听到小哥的声音
这个
时不时把以前的影片复习再复习
为生活增加很多乐趣
从理财答案秀到订阅PP
4月中的放空时诞课
上到8月的课
矫正很多错误的观念
每天反省自己的教育策略
大幅提高
户头总损益也都是正7%以上
那很强啊
正7%就很强
因为你做短线做到正7%很强了
全证跟现有损益也开始出现
表现百分之百以上的获利
恭喜恭喜
谢谢小哥指导
祝小哥及各位同学都能大赚
等开放实体课
一定要找
小哥朝圣的哈
我们什么时候开放呢
当各位普遍这个打了两季之后
我们就会开放
现在打一季
这个很多人都打一季
可是打一季感觉还是没那么安全
等到各位打了两季
那我可以不用戴口罩上课的话
我就会开放了
我就会上实体课
最重要的是我要抽大GG
有大GG的保佑才能限股跟全带一直硬挺
屈屈避凶远离密尿科远离六点半
好 恭喜你啦
这个得到了大
大奇奇得奖者
恭喜
好 那我们来看许主圈的战机分享
这个最近的标的有莲勇
莲勇
不过最近莲勇有稍微回档
回档
回档呢 你就要看什么
你要看阻力有没有跑
阻力有没有跑
月线有没有距离上升
那有的话
有的话 但靠近月线
你就可以考虑看看
那各位看一下这莲勇的认贡
哇塞这100多%哇80几%
因为莲勇呢这个
博传全镇买了之后他有喷出一段时间
有喷出所以各位看到喷出呢这个
全镇就赚很多啦
好那各位看这个另外的莲勇
很多人赚到莲勇啦
齐邦系格齐邦哇这个
齐邦系格也是老司机的标的啊
这个也是很多人赚到
威刚威刚
好 群创群创群创 连电
白红群创
群创那个是当冲的
当冲 那一天很多人冲 8月5号
你看一下是不是那一天啊
来看群创
对啊 就是这一天 8月5号
你看我们学员8月5号都赚钱
各位看到没有
这是一根黑K哦
我们都是黑K在赚钱的哦
有没有看到 不是 不是
这个不是红K赚钱
我先把关掉一下
好各位看到这个现股当冲
我们是赚钱是赚在黑K的时候
你会研究筹码的话
各位看8月5号是一堆人去追高群创
那一天群创我记得应该是当冲赔钱
当冲赔钱我们来看一下当冲赔钱
来看看印象中应该是要赔钱
来看这个历史模式
然后呢8月5号
8月5号
8月5号历史模式然后呢套用今日筹码当冲损益排一下看一下群创有没有赔钱
群创台股上市贵
找成交量大的
成交量大的应该看得出来
哇有啦
当天是赔钱
当天全市场群创赔了
499万
群创赔了499万
当天全市场
但是我们很多学员啊
当天的群创是赚钱的
我当天群创也是大赚的哦
我也是大赚的哦
那后来呢
你看后来后面的群创就下跌了
哦所以我们做这种筹码研究呢
哦做这种筹码研究其实
哦在做交易的时候
胜率呢会比别人高很多啦
哦会比别人高很多啊
你看群创8月5号
这个大家
这个合起来都赔钱
可是我们群组的学我们也没有带单啊
我也没有做在群组说
哎呀群创今天空爆他
也不做这种事情
但是这些人呢回去研究筹码有定PP的
他们就知道隔天群创应该怎么样
不要追不要追不要追
我们都会跟这个学员讲不要追不要追
为什么
因为我怕你跟我对坐
你容易受伤啊
你容易受伤
那有些人听懂了
哦不要追那
反手空下去好了
一空就赚钱了
一空就赚钱
好
来看这个群众
群众那天很多人赚
很多人赚
哎这个资券当冲的记得要改现股当冲哦
各位记得
哦别人都是现股当冲
结果你资券冲你要多缴交易税
哦好这个群
还是那天整资券冲
哎我看
哦对那可以现股当冲啊
对啊
可以现股当冲啊记得改过来
改过来
好
再看这个别的赚钱的
细创
我们说今天细创有全赠卖押
还真的有全赠卖押
再看其他训练的对账单
细格奇邦
张元
张元我们也说
这个是
地缘分点大卖的股票
最近也果然都是蛮弱的
地缘分点大卖的
果然怎么样
果然还是弱
有人问PP是什么
PP是什么
我待會留言底下就有連結啦
底下就有連結
我每天都會貼TPP的文章給各位看啦好 那這長榮起長榮起各位啊 明天扬明出关明天扬明出关我今天扬明我还要买到跌停版
跌停版的扬明
我挂单
就那一盘就跌停了
跌停我还买两盘
因为他有两盘都跌停
希望扬明明天开高
希望这样
好 接下来看万海长龙
这个我是
这个在扬明还没开
还没开高之前
先跟各位讲我有买
我现在库存有扬名
各位你看一下明天他的走势怎么样
不过假如冲很高的话
我可能也是会考虑会卖掉的
好
来看万海
万海很多学员赚钱
我们在PP文章里面
还交了一招
反亲赴明招
反万海买扬名招
空万海买扬名招
这一招呢
这个我们有学员做
做完之后
两个都赚钱
空万海赚钱
买阳明也赚钱
空万海买阳明招
那我们是充分利用了事件交易
加筹码判断
事件加筹码
再加上两个价格的乖离
我们用两个价格的倍率去看一下
他们在
在怎么样
他们在长时间的统计下
万海跟阳明
原本两个是1比1的
万海跟阳明的股价差不多
前阵子万海冲到了阳明的两倍
万海股价是阳明的两倍
那我们做什么事情呢
我们就是空万海买阳明
空万海买阳明
赌他会收敛
那最近他真的有收敛
真的有收敛
那这一招真的很好用
就是你空万海买阳明
这个盘中
不管海浪
多么波涛洶涌
你都不会晕船
为什么
你多空都有
你怕什么
你只不过赌
他的价格会收敛而已
那最近他的价格慢慢收敛
我觉得明天会收敛更多
因为明天的阳明
可能会蛮强的
明天的阳明
我说开盘
后面我不知道
这很难讲
反正呢
这只是猜测
明天你再看看
好
好 再看这个东美金金鸿天玉
好 这个旺宏
大宇之大宇之又学人赚到大宇之讲完之后喷出跳空一字线啊我们大宇之讲这个关键买超啊关键买超呢买一段时间
各位你看一下大宇之的现行
啊今天跳空一字线呢开高创高
啊这个点位啊这个点位有的人就卖掉股票了
真恭喜他啊恭喜他啊
大宇之呢这个也是关键买的股票啦
啊关键买的股票
好 再看杨明光建策童星店
童星店最近这个也还不错
好
那杨明光我们说是主投买
主投买有些人赚到钱啊
再看中刚运昌
运昌是空方标的
空方标的
好 再来看这个细创
细创 细创有赚到
细创 细创是今天的
细创我们说今天有全赠卖压
全赠卖压就赚到钱了
这边有很多是全证卖压赚到的
有的是波段全证
反正今天都好像是开
这个开盘就卖掉了
然后联电广语俱亨
叶辉 西创
这都旋转的 齐宏
齐宏 看世维航
世维航那天也很好做
8月9号
这个很好玩
很好做的一档股票
最近你有研究筹码的话
真的很好玩啊
哦
这个平常当中偶尔会赔钱吗
8月份还没赔过
哦8月份还没赔过
因为这种盘整偏空我们最爱做了
盘整偏空都是大大资产
都很好做
但是你就是要学会怎么去这个短空啦
好啦
这是学院的对账单
哦接下来呢
我们讲乐透哦
乐透呢
这个上个月没开哦
但是最近哦
从去年年底
到这个六月份都还蛮好做的
那下礼拜呢就是八月的热透了
我们再看八月热透怎么样
那各位有兴趣你可以去看热透的影音啦
因为这个内容差不多
不过今天今天我这个买了一个不是
不能算热透选择权里面的
标准做法
不过是热透选择权课里面的其中一段
其中一段我们有讲
周选择犬的杠杆大
所以今天我的周选择犬呢
做的蛮不错的
来看一下之前有一小四倍的
我今天做到十倍
那各位你看我们的对账单
这个像上次的
这个是股票期货对账
结算对账单
这个大部分都是赚钱的
那这个乐透选择群
我们有很多种模式
很多种模式赚钱
有价差单赚钱
这是价差交易的赚钱
那下单一定要靠自己研究
这个今天呢我们就会讲一个
这个今天十倍乐透的交易
我们上完课是分享获利秘诀
上完课是生活上好传统的交易
生活上好友交易上晋升者
因为我们连无风险交易都无私的交了
那给各位看
我在上个月对账单
上个月对账单我获利的拿掉了
我先给各位看
这个我的交易税
上个月交易税是368万
有没有觉得这四个字很熟啊
刚好怎么样
刚好就是我们学费的千分之一啊
但是各位
你假如是长期在理财宝里面
你一定会有一些
这个理财宝的金
这个理财宝金叫什么金我也忘了
反正有一些理财宝你报名的时候
还有一些理财宝的金可以折扣
折扣完你可能剩下3500或3400
好了
那这个我的各位的学费呢
就是我一个月交易税的千分之一
所以我们是有很多交易经验的
这是上个月
那这个月呢
我的量又更大了
这个月量又更大了
各位呢
我们首先来看这个月对账单
首先先给各位看我赔钱的对账单
昨天呢有跟各位讲
我的可成赔了400多万
就今天可成涨了嘛
各位呢我的口数都给你看
口数164口
长期呢我就是在100多口
很多人都问说小哥你的口数几口
我都说每次都跟他讲100口100口
我这次真的贴给各位看
均价187块
小哥你怎么买那么高
那是因为我们长期存股
长期在存可乘
那是每个月转仓的平均价格
每个月转仓还有这个月买的
这个平均下来就是187
那今天市价178
不动损益310万
付的赔钱的哦
那但是其实这一整年来
可乘这个起起伏伏的
其实以实践损益
是超过这个310万
以实践损益超过310万所以呢我现在可曾即便现在的股价是178我的可曾total还是赚钱的哦而且还是赚蛮多的哦还是赚蛮多的哦
那目前的报酬率是5%
我觉得还好还可以接受
那市值呢是5800万
不是我拿5800万出来
不是哦
可曾我们是用期货做的
用期货做的
所以呢
保证金可能大概就
八九百吧
保证金大概八九百
那我的这个部位啊
各位有没有看底下有绿色的
我的部位里面还有一堆空单
这些空单事实上都有在保护我的可乘
我的部位里面是很复杂的
所以呢我的可乘即便他这样点呢
我可乘也没有被追缴
但是你假如户头里面只有一档可乘
可能就被追缴了
但是我没有
因为我不只这一档股票
我有一堆股票
像之前我有如虹啊
我有如虹的空单
如果跟各位讲
就如红最近也蛮弱的
好
那可曾关键分点
今天也在买
好
赔钱给各位看一下
那这个月呢
我们利用了短空的交易
还有一些高档猪肉股的交易
这个月2号到11号
这个交易金额呢
大约是
这个户头大约是15亿
大概15亿
赚了388万
那这个15亿呢
它背后还有退用
这个户头还有退用
为什么
因为这个户头呢
它手续位有180万
我手续位就花了180万
但是180万里面呢
它会打折
会退回来一些
退回来一些
各位呢
你假如交易有量的话
你就可以跟你的营业园谈
它会退给你一些啦
好
那没有量的
你可能就
可能要找我们全组营业员
不然就很难谈这个退用
没有量也
也不大需要去谈退
有的人一个月做10万
那不用退了不用退
那就给营业就算了
这个当你做的很少的时候
那营业的基本的服务还是有的
所以呢那也不用谈退用
可是当你做的很大的时候
那就有机会谈一下
有机会谈一下
好那我这个月交易税已经缴了127万
那另外一个户头我缴了36万
其实我不止这两个户头
我还有很多户头
那我举这两个是比较大的
所以这个月呢
我交易税到今天为止已经缴了163万
163万所以呢我每次开车开在例如说我开车开在书花改上面我就觉得我做交易真的很有贡献这些道路都是我每天
一点一滴缴的交易税而铺陈的
我就觉得这个对社会国家都蛮有贡献
你看半个月就是150
一个月肯定
这个月肯定是大概破
一定是破400的
这个月一定是破400万的交易税
那一整年算起来
你看有可能就5000交易税
就5000万
5000万很多了
5000万这个你可以做很多工程
好
那这是另外一个户头
那这户头以时间水印
210万
报酬率呢
这一整月下来1%
那1%有的人都很不序
那1%
我们这个2亿
这个是每天大部分都是当冲
不是说拿2亿出来
拿2亿出来
然后做一个月赚1%
不是这样
大部分都是当冲掉了
当冲掉了
那我们当冲都是有策略的
不是凭感觉的
最近有一个网红
他po了一个
他当冲赔了几十万的影片
那到后来当然也是在业配
那个聊天交友的软体
因为他当冲美送
就去交朋友嘛
那但是我们不一样
我们是有策略有研究
有研究的做交易
那有研究做交易呢
长期而言他的胜率就是高
就是这样
所以每次都贴给各位看
这个我们是很认真的在缴税
所以呢
很多人跑去凯基松山
凯基台北去呛人家说
什么隔日冲啊害死人家
哎拜託你也不想想看
不想看這些
這些人繳多少交易稅
人家隔日沖也沒有穩賺啊
對不對
你看現在華航
常務航隔天都跳空開地啊
今天美騎馬變沙騎馬對不對
你看今天昨天買一堆
今天又開地
所以隔日沖也沒有穩賺的好不好
這怪人家隔日沖把股票弄低
那漲停的時候怎麼不講
漲停的時候也是一堆隔日沖啊
也是一堆隔日沖在買股票嘛
所以
所以这个不要怪短线客
不要怪短线客
那些怪短线客的都是韭菜
韭菜在怪人家那其实他对你的股票呢是有助长的效果假如你股票很强势的话他会一直帮你所涨停所以呢会有助涨的效果
那你股票弱势的话
本来就会弱了好不好
你股票弱势都是主力在出货造成的
主力出货造成的
我们今天就教你看怎么是主力
什么是主力
好 那我们新的课程群组聊天热络
各位你看我们已经到84群了
那我们的人数呢
很多都是500满边哦
500 500 500 500
499 499 498
很恐怖的哦
你很难看到一个群组
可以这样子500涨停所实实的
而且里面没什么在吵架的哦
我们群组里面很少吵架
偶尔会吵架
但很少在吵
所以加我们群组还是蛮幸福的
还是蛮幸福的
所以各位欢迎就生来上
新的主题课程
那聊天室来 聊天室刷一下吧
把你的群组刷一下 我来看一下
哇 现在有53 83 76 83
各位你可以在你的群组呢
每天讯息看不完 真的 我每天一看
晕倒 例如说你take我
我一看999 晕倒
这个划到我的名字 不晓得划到什么时候
哇你看
各位你看聊天室的群組啊
聊天室刷起來
哇塞很多勒刷不完
你看我們群組太多了
假如奧運有比賽群組的那個數目的話
我大概會得到冠軍了
因為為什麼
因為全台灣太
全台灣有人群組比我多的
麻煩留言一下吧
我好像沒有遇到群組比我多
因為我們的群組
這個忠誠度太高了
一堆499跟500
所以要群組比我多 我覺得有點困難
我們群組大概沒意外的話
這兩年一定會破百 破百群組
那以前想說破百群組還要整併一下
可是想想又好可惜
那這些人家聊得好好的
你要整併也很難整併
現在真的很難整併 我們只能慢慢加進去
很難整併進去
哇你看 我們的群組很多啦
聊天室 聊天室 哇非常多 非常多
希望小哥不要100群退休
本來想說100群可以退
不過現在看起來可能還不會退
那我科學可以分享
如果教出見聰聲
教各位我今天就直接講了
中生的六个字
六个字哦
多鼓励
小时候呢我儿子呢考试考不好
我都鼓励他
我都跟他讲说哎呀不要难过
那都是你们需要题目太难了
我就鼓励他
那下次他有进步
例如说30分到40分
我就哎呀太好了太好了
进步33%
MOM 33%太强了
你就可以这样子鼓励他
你鼓励他就会至少他会想学了
你骂他他就不想学了
好
那第二个呢要做题库
做考古题
就这样
那没了
好
好啦
那我们接下来看这个我的交易笔记本
交易笔记本呢
PP跟DP这两个是同样的东西
同样东西
那个看一下学员新的
谢小哥分享期待9月的放空课
我就排我月初会有放空课
这个另外一个
这个虽然在下雨
有上通道关键麦保护着我
每天小哥辛苦的研究
看到中华店主投板心里有数了
就是怎么样
就是这个中华店主投板就代表盘很弱了啦
谢谢小哥真的用生命在燃烧
写PP开始低低低
从不懂到现在没有小哥外面之一
我相信小哥从来已经得到满满钞票
老司机真的活塞雷啊
好小哥是散户的救星
好现在看
这个
听小哥的PP超疗愈
真的
好小哥除了筹码分析厉害
时间管理更是大师级
可以兼顾这么多事情做交易
嗯我们做交易真的做蛮多的
录PP每天录
上节目一个礼拜一两次
开直播每个礼拜开
开堂授课
以上任何一项做的好
称为专家哦
我真的每个都有做
好啦
感谢你的花奖啦
好
这个是PP的心得啦
那这个月的
不是这个
这个礼拜PP
我们来看一下标题哦
主头买阳明光大涨
樊轩大涨
关键买慧阳大涨
关键买世界涨停
主头买金利科大涨
关键买华邦店大涨
好在后面呢
主头买阳明光大涨
短线果然不能追高
因为我们都有讲
短线你不要去追涨停版的股票哦
现在涨停版的股票
跟以前不一样了
不一样
以前呢
是主力拉到涨停
隔天继续买
现在没有
现在是主力拉到涨停
当天就在砍股票了
当天就在砍你知道吗现在阻力狠狠的先拉到涨停让你追你追完之后他涨停板就在砍股票他不等隔天的隔天都直接跳空开地
隔天直接跳空开地
很恐怖的
所以我们讲短线不要追高
不要追高
好
那我们8月8号呢
有讲高档阻力卖少买
急跑辅助增加案例
好
那我们的这个
PP的序列率超高
93%这么高
太高了太高了
这个不管是报纸啊有线电视啊
他们的流存率都很难这么高
都很难这么高
好那我今天呢我会特别解析一下
我的解析很简单
大概一分钟就讲完了
选择权十倍的技巧
我今天买乐透选择权
我待会给你看实际的证据哦
我为何在10点28分14秒买这个选择权
买这个选择权
这个我忘了是这应该是挂单还是
成交我忘了
反正我掛單到成交呢
這個時間差不多
這個是應該是掛單跟成交時間差不多
那這個是掛單之後等了一下子成交
等一下子成交反正時間就在那邊
這是我直接截圖下來的
我買12點賣120點
12點多少錢呢
12點一口就是600塊台幣而已
600塊當天變成6000塊
LTV是什麼LTV
就是
就是订阅的人
他订阅的人
平均啦
平均到目前为止
平均在这个专案上
花了一万四
这平均的意思
好
那我们再看一下
再回来看
这个
看这样
这个12点到120点
12点的你买的是600块
120点的卖的是6000块
一天
一天达标
一天打标
其实不到一天了
两个半小时不到
十倍
那这个常常是在
礼拜三周选择权的时候会发生
我们的讲义也有特别写
礼拜三周选择权会发生这个事情
600进去6000出来
真的
这个大宏说的对
好
那我们来看
我不是买在最低
我也不是卖在最高
没有
没这么厉害
我是买在这个位置
12点这个位置我卖在什么位置我卖在应该是这个位置这附近的位置我卖在120点我卖在这个位置所以呢这是1分k
1分k我刻意卖120
刻意卖120
因为120刚好10倍
刚好10倍
所以我刻意卖在120点
我也不卖120
也不卖120
就是要卖在120
就是为了10倍
为了这个标题
为了标题
选择选10倍技巧
好啦 那我今天在PP呢 我還沒錄
待會 待會課後我就來跟各位講
這10倍怎麼賺來的
只花一分鐘時間 你就知道我的買賣點
你就知道我為什麼 我會告訴你為什麼要買
我不是隨便滑的啦
我是告訴你 我看到了什麼跡象
然後我去買這個選擇權
然後呢 我看到什麼跡象 我出場
10倍
好
那其實我今天盤中我也不曉得會10倍
這盤中一看
哎呦五倍了六倍
那看看能不能10倍
還真的是10倍
好
那我們來看一下籌碼K的五大指標
首先最重要最重要最重要
叫做主力買賣超
那買賣超呢是買超前15米合計
跟賣超前15米合計
這相減
相減啦
那買賣超累計呢是看統計訊息的買賣超
那各位呢買賣超呢
你就記得兩個東西
两个东西
第一个
低档主力大买
股价没涨偏多操作
这句话
就是股票在低档
这个低档各位会看嘛
低档
来来来
我们给各位看什么叫低档
什么叫低档
你把时间拉长拉长拉长
你把它拉长你就知道
哎呦这就是低档嘛
那最近呢
你就看
假如有一天主力开始买超的话
那最近主力还在卖
卖可是也跌不大下去
卖跌不下去你要注意
那有低檔主力转买
那可能就是发动的讯号
低檔主力转买可能就发动
所以这个看到低檔高檔
你就是把时间拉长
你就一看就知道
这看起来是低檔嘛
低檔的股票那有没有可能更低
当然有可能啊
我没办法跟你保证他会不会更低
那不过至少怎么样
至少最近主力卖
那今天呢也涨了2.3%
今天大盘跌那么多
他也算是
比较撑得一档股票了好那我们再看哎我们再来看一下第二个高档主力大卖股价没跌偏空操作
什么叫高档主力大卖呢
我们讲的像最近聚合
很多人都在推这档股票
他高档主力大卖
这个就要小心一点
高档主力大卖就要小心
各位你今天呢你只要呢
只要会这两个就好
低檔跟高檔
只要會這兩個
等一下
把他關掉
好
接下來我們來看散戶買賣超
散戶買賣超呢
我們就看散戶的動向
那散戶的動向呢
一向都是怎麼樣
一向都是散戶都是被鼓吹的
鼓吹
那鼓吹呢是什麼狀況會鼓吹
像之前地亞股很紅的時候
就是這個爆料同學會的林媽媽
林妈妈
林妈妈就鼓吹人家
这个艺人一张买DR
买DR
鼓吹要去101看美德伊
要去101看美德伊
要包场
后来呢
美德伊目标价101块
有没有到
有到了
101块目标到了
是101块的日币
日币
因为现在日币
大概值25块
那美德伊真的是101块
现在连101块日币都还不到
都还不到 因为剩19块了
那这个就是你在高档发现
散户大买就要小心
我们讲了很多次
高档散户买就准备怎么样
准备下山了
散户被骗到山头了
被骗到山头就准备下山
果然你看真的就跌下来
真的跌下来
所以可以看散户买超
白超
各位你假如看到散户大買股票高檔的
你可以來問我
小哥這檔股票散户
大買股票高檔
我就告訴你怎麼樣
如何空他SOP
我會告訴你
空他的SOP
我們有一套SOP
超好用的
SOP有90%
90%賺錢的機率
真的90%
我不相信你去看一下
10檔中9檔
因为你要按照这SOP
第一步第二步第三步
你按照123步的你去做
你会发现你胜率超级高
超級高
好 接下來看萬鎧
萬鎧呢他就屬於高檔
主力賣 有沒有看到 高檔主力賣散戶
高檔進來喔 因為散戶只有這麼少
慢慢上來 萬鎧就是
高檔主力賣散戶買的股票
所以萬鎧要特別小心喔
萬鎧要特別小心喔 現在
紅K的隔天呢很容易都很弱
所以萬鎧你不要去搶喔 真的很恐怖的股票
好 接下來我們看大戶散戶持股比
這個呢也很清楚
也很清楚
好 我們來看這個大戶散戶持股比例
這個字遮到了
這個呢 我們可以看到籌碼的流向
例如說長榮
大家最愛的長榮
各位有沒有看到大戶一路的往下降
一路的往下降
那代表貨都出給散戶了嘛
一堆散户都当航海王
为什么最近没亮
因为散户都套牢在长龙的山上
所以就没亮啊
我们在长龙233这一天
发了一个YouTuber跟各位讲
长龙的全镇大户出厂
你假如看到那个YouTuber你也不会想买长龙
发完到现在跌了100块钱
跌了100块
所以我们那个影片发的时间点是
算过的好不好
我是算过的
算时间发影片的
各位你可以看我youtube影片
我是算时间发影片
发完跌100块
那影片很经典的
经典的这个时间点
挑的非常好
挑那天发
故意的
为什么故意发那天呢
因为
以后在直播的时候
就可以拿出来讲嘛
拿出来讲
你看看我当年发的影片发的多么准
那些都是证据
你可以去看
你可以去看那个我们的
这个长龙的影片
长龙大户都在下车
股票大户下车
全镇大户下车
散户在上车
为什么散户都在买长龙呢
因为散户呢都去听老师的话
听这个市面上的老师啊
或市面上的网红啊
好 网红跟老师我们讲SOP 来讲SOD不是SOD啦SOP不要看错了
这个我们
市面上网红跟老师都叫你买
航海的
叫你买航海这张股票啊
但是我们从筹码一看
筹码大二户就在出
散户就在买
这一看就知道怎么样
一看就知道
股票呢怎么样
不能买
你即便要买 只有抢反弹
只有抢反弹可以
你不能怎么样
你不能做波段多
不行 不行的
接下我们看了 急保护数
急保护数 自诱这道
急保护数呢 各位看一下
高档急保护数增加
对股价有伤害哦
各位来看一下 有没有伤害
很大的伤害
长龙在四个月前
长龙的
吉保负数多少人呢
20万
现在呢
48万
原本长龙
长龙这台标股
上面原本长龙
是一台特斯拉
跑车
现在已经变成印度的火车了
印度火车为什么
因为多了多少人
多了快30万人
多了30万人
坐在长龙的车上
啊这怎么标啊
这很难标啦
很难标
它只能慢慢的往下降
慢慢往下降
这个是蛮危险的
好
那我们把以上这几个指标合在一起看
我们就可以看到一张股票叫做聚合
那聚合这个呢
各位看一下
你可以预言到
可以预测到
今天容易跌
想不到居然是跌停
各位看一下聚合啊
这里啊
主力卖散户买
吉保护数增加
大户呢长期来看他是减少
那这个突然增加可能是格子冲进来
散户呢长期来看最近已经增加了
长期来看最近增加
有没有看到
主力卖散户买吉保护数增大户
这减散户增
这一看就知道有问题
有问题哦
我们在什么时候写
8月8号
礼拜天我们在礼拜天就写就写怎么样各位聚合他是一個主力賣傻物買吉保護身他是一個標準的什麼東西啊
標準的高檔出貨股
聚合我們就講他是高檔主力賣商的股票
我們只挑六七檔而已
裡面就有檔聚合
然後他有SOP
各位我們挑的時候聚合股價長這樣喔
各位你看一下現在長怎樣
現在聚合長這樣
650有現在長這樣剩55塊
挑的時候
挑的時候多少錢
挑的時候62塊
62塊現在剩55
10天
10天呢就跌了這個
7塊錢
跌了10%啦
跌了10%
好這個我們有SOP
SOP写在
這個PP的
裡面
裡面有寫
好
那我們再看
我利用高檔出貨的SOP
這兩天喔
這兩天
8月10號8月11號
我的聚合呢
已實現
這是已實現
我還有未實現
還有未實現
因為今天跌停了
跌停通常我都等明天
這個開盤的時候回補
不管是開高開低
開低本來就要補
除非又跌停
那開高也就代表說
哎这个点呢可能是稍微休息一下
我也会补
反正这两个
明天我开盘因为跌停
跌停我说没有补完
假如没有跌停的话
我大概今天就补完了
好那聚合呢
这个户头呢就赚了29万
我们就是利用高档出货的
SOP
好啦
那关键分点也很重要哦
这个筹码指标关键分点很重要
来给各位看一下我们厉害的上轨手门员
如虹啊 如虹上回首门员
哇 守得特别好
守完之后他就下跌了
这边 守得很好
好 那东森呢 之前有跟各位讲
东森这个关键分点
卖在55块
那时候股价到71块
我们就讲
这档股票你看看
以后这个分点
这个分点 你看看
最终他卖的价格
对不对
卖的价格对不对
我们从现在来看
他卖的价格非常漂亮
因为他现在只剩下40块不到40块不到了他卖平均价55各位呢有一堆老师推荐你买东森
你的货都被他怎么样
你买的货都是这个主力到货的啦
主力到货到给你的啊
这主力呢一天可以到7000张啦
7000张我看你这个我们之前都预告
那种股票后面要小心
果然最近都跌的哩哩啦
好 那我们筹码可以课程呢
我们交筹码获利七大招
1 飙风向上挑股招
2 神秘券商布局招
3 地缘券商大揭秘
4 大单券商解密招
盘中大单券商教你怎么看
那5 6 7
这个神秘的招式
我们在礼拜天就会交给各位啦
礼拜天
礼拜天学费只要3600多而已
很便宜
这个你付的学费
就让我交给国家去照桥铺路了
照桥铺路了
这我所有学费
一定不够付这个交易税的
不够付交易税
我们交易税太多了太多了
好
那我们当中十三课呢
有交这么多个课纲
这个各位我们教很多
这个最近当中都赚钱哦
我们不是随便冲的
是有研究过在冲的
所以各位当冲赔钱的
你可以回去看6月27号的影音
6月27号影音
好
那么从来可以事丸专丸
今天讲了一档股票
这档股票关键买跟主投
关键买主投买哦
好各位这是关键
关键最近在买
主力最近在买
投信最近也在买
很难得看到这三个都在买了
那在这盘式震荡之际
各位想要怎么做
这张股票也算是大的股票
不是小股票
这是大的股票哦
上回高点关键是在卖股票的哦
上回高点关键是大卖哦
在这边大卖
最近买回来了
所以各位你可以看一下
好那加入小哥
小哥籌碼K社團好處
大家一同研究籌碼K
了解籌碼流向
分辨籌碼多空啊
可以一起討論同档標記
標定了解不同人的看法
那我們上課送四大好禮
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:00:00 起〕